n'est pas pro mail de bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui qu'il revient à clé
nicolas vial mais non c'est écrit nous
arrivons sans faute
aujourd'hui vous aurez pas vite
alors mais là on attend rien alors
qu'ils sortent de les femmes bonsoir les
gens de nous tuer que vient vie d'où
j'arrive on avec un peu de retard nous
avons eu un petit incident au bourguet
mais vous venez vous venez avec avec le
sida je n'ai rien c'est ma boussole qui
ne marchait pas bien
ah bon on pas de pêcher vous à la
hauteur jusqu'à st mais nous sommes là a
tout de suite à gauche les bains selon
jusqu'à 1,5 à 2,5 me dis que la triche
pas bon non droit
calais 5 les vols à l'heure
bonsoir tous nos amis bon et bien nous
voilà revenus j'espère que tout s'est
très bien passé pendant notre absence et
que vous êtes vite allez vous coucher
chaque soir reçu leur patron ce sucre et
bien je suis très content mais qu'est ce
que tu as hâte agité ainsi mon cher
nounours lot de nombreux tubes petit
sony wii descend vite nounours mais ne
traîne pas car après ce long voyage
il est temps que nous allions dormir
nous aussi au bout le jeune homme
beaucoup de bobos bourse au mes petits
[Musique]
oignons tu calmes les enfants du col
tout d'abord comment se porte notre
petit ami philippe heures et votre bien
nous dans une campagne où il a beaucoup
de classe pour corée pour jouer en effet
notre bonne ville sur cette photo est
bien puisque vous avez bien soigné ce
put
moi je vous ai apporté au choix
s'annonce quelque chose de bon pour
votre petit vent doit et que vous aimez
beaucoup tenu secret ce bateau qui les a
fait cela non c'est ma tante dhabi que
je suis allé voir à la montagne dans les
hautes pyrénées
il les a confectionnées avec amour pour
au les petits gourmands ils les ont déjà
bondi pour qu'elle nous en envoie
d'autres avouent d'accord les enfants
mais à condition que vous alliez vite au
dodo shirt en tête
quelques heures dans halo
les grands voyageurs à des ménages vol
de nuit des petits seins
huit cas là on n'est pas problème
[Musique]
tous aussi les petits enfants aller vite
au dodo comme nicolas et pimprenelle et
nous supporterons et bien à demain bonne
nuit fais de beaux rêves
beaubourg peu
[Musique]